ich habe ihn eben schon angesprochen und
wir haben ihnen eben beitrag auch schon
gesehen wolodimir das ziel lenski hat
dann heute nacht etwa 3 uhr 45 sich
nochmal an die welt gewendet blogs das
sind bloß die
wärmebildkameras ausgestattet sind dass
es sie wissen worauf sie schießen sie
haben sie sich darauf vorbereitet ich
wenn sie mich an alle ukraine an einen
europäer an alle menschen die wissen was
bedeutete tschernobyl die wissen wie
viele opfern die explosion in
tschernobyl brachte das war eine globale
katastrophe
hunderte tausende von menschen haben das
bekämpft dutzende von tausenden wurden
evakuiert russland möchte das
wiederholen aber und das selbst von
europäer bitte wacht auf sagt zu euren
politikern die russischen truppen
beschießen akw in der ukraine
wir sprachen mit unseren partner mit
unseren staatschefs ich habe gesprochen
mit michael mit scholz methode mit
präsident biden wir haben gesprochen mit
dem leiter von magath große auch mit dem
premierminister johnston wir waren alle
kein land außer russland hat jemals die
energie blogs beschossen das ist zum
ersten mal in unserer geschichte in der
geschichte der menschheit dass ein staat
terrorist wendet sich anderen nukleare
dennoch die russischen terroristen haben
gedroht mit nuklearer asche die welt zu
überschütten jetzt ist das keine große
gefahr das ist real und wir wissen nicht
womit diese
die feier dieser band auf dem akw endet
da eine explosion
da stattfindet das können wir nicht
voraus und unsere jungs haben diesel-pkw
immer sicher gehalten damit keine diese
akw wie nieren mit - versorgen kann und
anschließend die ganze welt mit einer
nuklearkatastrophe zu erpressen müssen
es müssen die russischen militärs müssen
aufgehalten sagt zu euren politikern
wenn es zur explosion kommt dann ist das
ende das ende für alle das ist die
evakuierung von europa nur und
versöhnliche gelungen von europe können
die russischen truppen anhalten damit
keine katastrophe auf dem akw
stattfindet